et notre première invitée politique de
l'année c'est donc vous marc fesneau
bonjour bon merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous ce matin ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne et on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
fabrice les cerveaux dont jean fabrice
bonjour aurillac bonjour moqueries dont
fabrice du groupe ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france on va
bien sûr longuement parlé avec vous un
marc fesneau de ce texte sur le pass
vaccinale est d'abord un mot sur le
climat dans lequel ce texte arrive au
sénat contexte un peu tendu on a vu ce
week-end une augmentation du nombre de
manifestants anti passent plus de cent
mille selon le ministère de l'intérieur
et puis il ya quelques heures à saint
pierre et miquelon un député de la
république en marche des femmes clairoix
été violemment agressé devant son
domicile par des manifestants anti pas
ce qu'est ce que vous avez pensé par la
vie de ces neiges j'ai trouvé ces images
au fond assez effrayante parce que de
voir un homme seul d'entre eux bien
qu'il est chez lui d'abord et que deux
ils cherchent plutôt le dialogue se fait
rejeter toutes sortes d'objets autre
chose devant son domicile avec une
flafla la véhémence une foule un peu
déchaîné il ya quelque chose d'assez
effrayant de ce que son de ce qu'est
devenu débat politique où le débat
public c'est un jeu lady a partout et
d'ailleurs c'est un degré supplémentaire
dans la violence qui est faite aux élus
l'occasion de rendre hommage à tous les
élus d'ailleurs de tous horizons
politiques parce qu'il ne suffit pas
d'être dans la majorité pour être
menacée et on est parfois parce qu'on
est dans la majorité mais parfois aussi
parce que dans l'opposition fait le
choix de voter telle ou telle mesure et
ça ne ce n'est pas acceptable en
démocratie
justement c'est ce que j'allais dial ce
n'est pas supportable en démocratie
qu'au fond des élus soit dans toutes les
décisions et tous les actes de la vie
d'un élu qui est une la vie d'un élu
c'est un une vie de réflexion et c'est
une vidéo prise de décisions qu'on soit
un élu national d'ailleurs où qu'on soit
un élu local si à chaque moment à chaque
fois que vous devez prendre une décision
vous posez la question de savoir quelles
ont été les conséquences non pas
politique mais les conséquences
physiques de menaces qui vont porter sur
vous et plus grave encore sur votre
famille et dans les deux cas c'est grave
je pense que vous voyez bien la pression
que vous mettez et au fond vous fait
peser sur l'élu le l'idée qu'il ne peut
pas prendre sa décision en toute liberté
moi je pense que c'est une chose
extrêmement de rage le devoir de
l'ensemble responsables publics c'est de
condamner sans aucune objection sans
aucune oui mais eh oui ici sans aucune
objection il faut condamner ces actes là
parce que ça au bout au bout c'est le
totalitarisme au bout quand vous mettez
des élus nationaux ou locaux à la
pression physique ça veut dire que c'est
la loi du plus fort qui s'impose est la
loi du plus fort qui s'impose c'est le
totalitarisme et ça ça n'est pas
acceptable en démocratie joie beaucoup
d'élus encore la semaine dernière
d'ailleurs à l'assemblée nationale qui
se sentent en permanence qui ont alors
peut-être à tort d'ailleurs mais en tout
cas c'est quelque chose épié menace est
regardée avec le sentiment que ici sur
un bord de route là au pied de leur
domicile ici à la sortie des hémicycles
ils peuvent être menacés par un individu
est donc à toutes fins en permanence il
faut qu'on conçoit les uns et les autres
solidairement pas entre nommé solidaire
de la démocratie la démocratie
elle exige du débat de la confrontation
mais elle exige aussi la non violence
c'est c'est avec la violence ce n'est
plus la démocratie qui s'impose c'est
autre chose et moi je je je serai le
premier vous savez que depuis très
longtemps je je mets en garde les
responsables publics y jettent à la
vindicte populaire en disant allez chez
eux allaient alors domicile aller
manifester devant l'assemblée nationale
parce qu'en france dans ça c'est pas les
élus seulement qu'on menace c'est là les
règles de vie démocratique qui sont les
nôtres et donc je pense qu'on a tous une
responsabilité oui les mots avec lequel
je le fais
on a tous une responsabilité c'est de
faire vivre le débat démocratique en a
le droit de ne pas être d'accord avec le
pass veille sanitaire ou le pass
vaccinale mais on n'a pas le droit de
menacer quelqu'un à raison de ses
opinions marc fesneau vous avez le
sentiment qu on a franchi une nouvelle
nouveau palier en terme de violence en
termes de radicalité est ce que j'ai vu
hier les images que j'ai vues hier
venant de saint pierre et béton et
saint-pierre-et-miquelon ses 6000
habitants c'est une petite commune
française achats échelle que des gens
viennent se permettent de faire ça je
trouve qu'on a franchi un échelon il ya
tout ce qu'on ne voit pas c'est à dire
tous les élus qui parfois au gré dans
leur permanence avec leurs
collaborateurs auxquels je pense aussi
qu'ils aussi se sent pas menacé
sont en permanence sous la contrainte et
donc là on a franchi en tout cas
visiblement puisque les images parlent
d'elles mêmes 1° qui était vrai
insupportable je sais que l'arrêt
procédure le ministre de l'intérieur et
les éléments de la justice seront en
cours qui vont se mettre en route et
j'espère qu'on retrouvera les auteurs de
ces faits qui sont
faits le garde des sceaux et le ministre
de l'intérieur eric dupond moretti et
gérald darmanin ont indiqué à plusieurs
reprises auprès d'ailleurs du président
de l'assemblée nationale en particulier
mais nous en parlions la semaine
dernière avec le président larcher je
crois qu'on partage les deux assemblées
partage avec au gouvernement cette
exigence et cette préoccupation
ces renforcements auprès des personnes
qui peuvent être menacés de ses toutes
les menaces qui traînent sur internet et
où il faut aller chercher dès qu'on peut
les gens et les auteurs de ces menaces
les propos d'emmanuel
enfin honnêtement rien à voir ne
convient pas découvrir les faits
violence on l'a dit on les a découverts
au moment de la crise du gilet jaune
donc ne faisons pas des corollaires ou
dès le présent la république a dit au
fond ce que beaucoup de français disent
eux-mêmes
si vous n'avez pas entendu ces propos là
et voir plus fort à l'endroit de ceux
qui n'étaient pas vaccinés tu crois pas
que ce soit ça qu'ils soient liés le
président de la république il ay là il a
rappelé qu'elle était et note qu elles
étaient nos stratégies avec ses mots
avec les mots aussi de l'inquiétude
de d'un haut responsable public du
président de la république au premier
chef de convoi la santé
mais moi je pense que la responsabilité
première d'un président de la république
c'est de protéger les français et l'art
et le risque principal des français
c'est le risque des non vaccinés d'abord
pour eux et ensuite pour l'ensemble de
la société parce que ça fait peser un
risque pour
sûr sur le système de santé et donc je
pense que c'est ça le premier élément de
responsabilité c'est de protéger la vie
des gens et il n'est pas allé trop loin
selon vous mais il l'a dit avec ses mots
et moi ça ne me suffit
peut-être pas mais peu importe c'est pas
le sujet je pense que le président de
l'areq
le président de la république il est
dans son rôle qui est celui de protéger
les français s'ils n'avaient pas dit ce
qu'il avait dit au mois de juillet
première étape qui était le pass
sanitaires on lui avait déjà reproché à
l'époque des allé un peu fort je trouve
que il dit et il traduit au fond la
pensée de beaucoup de français et quand
on est président la république c'est
aussi ça le sujet j'étais encore ce week
end en fin de week-end dans mon
département je vous prie de croire que
ce que j'ai entendu c'est plutôt des
gens qui trouvaient effectivement il
fallait que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités le texte sur le pacs
nike arrive donc au sénat aujourd'hui
est ce que ces propos du président de la
république dont on parle beaucoup
parlementaires n'y a pas que les
français comparent les parlementaires
aussi en parle est-ce que ça complique
l'examen du texte on entend des
parlementaires disent je ne sais plus
très bien du coup
oui il faut passer faut pas moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour l'ensemble des
parlementaires ou le savez c'est
consubstantiel attendait c'est
consubstantiel amenons la vérité c'est
non ceux qui veulent voter pour votre on
pourrait que ceux qui veulent voter
contre ne se cache pas derrière des
arguments qui n'en sont pas
moi je respecte les positions de chacun
par nature est il que à l'assemblée
nationale comme au sénat je pense qu'on
a réussi avec le sénat l'assemblée
nationale trouver un calendrier qui
permet de de débats dans des conditions
qui sont deux conditions
satisfaisantes eu
son temps jean
castex théo raison de rappeler que
au final la
lecture s'est un peu accéléré à la
centrale pouvait se poser la question de
voir s'il n'y a pas une possibilité
d'accélérer au sénat le sénat avait pris
un certain nombre de dispositions
on est resté sur le schéma initial très
bien enfin il ya aucune difficulté avec
sa fin je moi je suis pas de ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut accélérer les
processus pour les accélérer le pr le
point miss a juste rappelé qu
effectivement manifestement on pensait
finir plus tôt jeudi dans la journée on
a fini jeudi matin très tôt et que
peut-être ça permettait mais au fond le
polémiste il est très soucieux aussi du
bon travail parlementaire il en a
dialogué avec le président du sénat
comme j'en avais une longue et moi même
aujourd'hui en commission demain et
après demain en séance ça permet de
regarder le texte dans des conditions
qui soient satisfaisantes pour les
sénateurs je crois j'ai pas entendu pour
le coutier difficulté de ce point de vue
là ça permettra un débat serein apaisé
et un débat qu'ils aillent au fonds
en tout cas les conditions sont posées
pour qu'il soit je ne suis pas sénateur
je les connais pas mal mais je ne
prétends pas parler en leur nom et donc
on verra dans quelle mesure les débats
permettront au fond est ce que c'est ça
qu'il faut regarder c'est le fond du
texte
de doter le gouvernement de doter la
puissance publique d'un certain nombre
d'outils qui permettront là encore de
travailler sur comment dirais-je sur la
régulation de cette pandémie je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le sénat sur le pass
sanitaires pour le coup contrairement à
l'assemblée nationale pour ce qui est
des élèves le sénat s'était prononcé
favorablement dans sa grande majorité
pourquoi parce qu'il estimait que
c'était donc je fais confiance aux
sénateurs et au sénat et la majorité
sénateurs est ce que je sais ils savent
être au rendez-vous de l'esprit de
responsabilité je n'ai pas de doute là
dessus oui est ce que je dis bienvenue à
l'assemblée nationale
on verra je prêt je présage pas je
ferais offense aux sénateurs mais après
il y aura une commission mixte parce que
le sénat va faire des modifications on
verra tout ça mais je sais que le sénat
dans ces cas là est à la hauteur de ses
responsabilités j'ai eu le vote
l'assemblée nationale qui était un peu
confondante côté l air un tiers un tiers
un tiers
battant une absence de ligne la vérité
c'est quand on n'a pas les lignes voilà
ce que ça produit ça veut dire que
d'ailleurs ils seraient en situation de
majorité il n'aurait pas fait voter le
pass sanitaire le pass vaccinale ce
qu'ils n'ont pas de majorité pour le
faire ce communiqué est un sujet pour
des gens qui veulent gouverner d'être à
ce point diviser sur un sujet qui est un
sujet
éminent d'urgence sanitaire et donc je
trouve que de ce point de vue là il ya
une petite interrogation qui peut naître
dans les esprits de nos concitoyens sur
le fond du texte
fication caduque si la situation
sanitaire s'améliore c'est des questions
sur le contrôle de ce pass vaccinale est
ce que vous êtes prêts à suivre les
recommandations les propositions du
sapin on verra quelles sont les
recommandations à la commission se
réunit aujourd'hui avait à examiner les
amendements il y aura une séance demain
et après demain dc nous regarder ce que
seront les abonnements je rappelle que
dans 75% des cas le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale trouve les voies d'un
compromis au travers des commissions
mixtes paritaires donc c'est des choses
qui arrivent c'est pas des exceptions
c'est plutôt la règle
la preuve que non le gouvernement
puisque on est sur ces dispositions là
et qu après la partie à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat de se mettre
d'accord ou non
on n'a jamais été fermé les
modifications l'a fait d'ailleurs à
l'assemblée nationale je le rappelle sur
la question du post vaccinale pour les
mineurs pour les moins de 16 ans donc on
n'est pas fermés au débat c'est de
l'intérêt du débat parlementaire c'est
pour ça qu'il faut lui donner du temps
en même temps on a quand même quelques
éléments qui nécessite qu'on aille aussi
vite que possible et donc je pense qu'on
peut on verra sur ces questions là et
sur d'autres s'il ya moyen de trouver un
terrain de compromis on verra comment se
passe la commission justement maintien
de temps gabriel attal parler du 17
janvier c'est à dire c'est la semaine
prochaine pour la mise en oeuvre du
passant vaccinale
c'est jouable c'est jouable je peux pas
vous en dire plus oui c'est jouable
c'est jouable
conditions pour que ce soit joie parce
que je même s'il ya un accord il ya une
nouvelle lecture qui peut se faire dans
la semaine ce qui aura un recours au
conseil constitutionnel
tout ça fait que ça reste joie dès qu'on
sera dans les horizons qui avait été
fixée je rappelle qu'au démarrage on
était plutôt sûr fin janvier début
février et qu'on reste dans les horizons
de la mi-janvier
mais très bien chacun poindra je vais
vous dire chacun va prendre ses
responsabiltés je pense que les français
nous regardent
que parfois les exercices qui sont faits
dans les médias sont pas des exercices
de gens qui sont très responsables de ce
que j'ai vu à l'assemblée nationale ne
m'a pas forcément rassuré de ce point de
vue la mêlée et allez vous arrêter les
gens du nord garde les gens qui
s'intéressent au débat parlementaire et
qui ont le sentiment que tandis que nous
les époux menons en veine querelle il a
le virus monté un certain nombre de gens
qui ne sont pas vaccinés ne sont pas
protégés on ne protège pas des autres et
le système de santé donc chacun prendra
les responsabilités qu'il apprend nous
nous prenons les nôtres je crois qu'on
peut reconnaître et que les français
reconnaissent que nous ayons à chaque
fois pris nos responsabilités quand
souvent et trop souvent malheureusement
d opposition n'est pas pris leurs
responsabilités quand vous regardez ce
qui se passe en allemagne en italie ou
ailleurs souvent quand même les
majorité-opposition réussi à trouver un
terrain d'entente pourquoi parce que il
avait un esprit de responsabilité
j'appelle responsable du tali juste
moyen et la mise en place de la
vaccination obligatoire pour les plus de
50 ans pourquoi ne pas être allé au bout
de ses promesses le chemin et mettre en
place les estimations du gâteau plutôt
que de faire ça pour une raison simple
et très bien rappelé qui a été pour une
raison simple qui a été très bien
rappelé par le président de la
république une fois vous mettez en place
l'obligation vaccinale comment vous la
mettez en oeuvre vous allez chercher des
gens chez eux ou les emprisonner ou les
embastiller jusqu'à ce qu'on ait trouvé
un moment
mais en italie il démarre au rendez vous
dans quelques semaines par ailleurs
manifestement étant le pays du monde je
crois pas dire de bêtises ou l'inde et
pays du monde où là le taux de
vaccination est le plus élevé
manifestement notre stratégie n'est pas
si mauvaise lorsque ramos qu'on avait
entendu le pass le post vaccinaux c'est
pour éviter de mettre des gens en prison
non mais voyez bien mais voyez bien que
ceux qui disent qu'il faut faire
l'obligation vaccinale c'est
l'impuissance publique qu'on prépare
c'est une fois qu'on a dit ça comment on
fait
on veut on va chercher des gens devant
le gendarme et on les amène un sillon de
la clim à sion obligatoire en france
elles sont obligatoires mais ça veut pas
dire que le taux de vaccination est à
100% on est à 92 % la vaccination est
obligatoire pour les enfants les neuf
vaccins dont on avait faim elle est
obligatoire tous les enfants sont pas
vaccinés
donc c'est pas parce qu'elle est
obligatoire qu'elle est appliquée
la question c'est pas qu'elle soit
obligatoire la question c'est quelles
soient le plus largement répandu et la
vaccination obligatoire ne rend pas tous
les enfants vaccinés donc faux faux faux
faut arrêter de dire ça il faut arrêter
de 2 quand on est un responsable public
ça peut être séduisant la vaccination
obligatoire mais je répète vous allez
chercher les gens entre deux gendarmes
ou les années dans les centres de
vaccination donné à des gens qui gagnent
à peine le smic une amende de 1500 euros
mais faut être sérieux c'est pas comme
ça qu'on gouverne un pays dont qu'on a
on est effectivement fait le choix de
pousser
sur le sur l'orientation vaccinale en
faisant peser la charge effectivement
sur ceux qui n'étaient pas vaccinés mais
sinon on est inopérant d'ailleurs le
seul territoire de la république qui a
fait rendu la vaccination obligatoire
c'est la nouvelle calédonie puisqu'ils
ont des prérogatives de santé et le
résultat n'est pas là non plus parce que
c'est comme ça que ça se passe là
la réalité humaine n'est pas celle là en
tout cas dans une démocratie quand on
n'est pas dans un régime démocratique
c'est facile de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire
arguments des opposants et à l'atteinte
aux libertés surtout dans une période où
le parlement est plus sensé siéger
puisque entre fin février et fin juin le
parlement n'est pas sensé siéger pour
cause de coupe est toujours 6 juin c'est
la question que j'allais vous poser est
ce qui pourrait être convoqué serait
juridiquement il peut siéger
mais on n'envisage pas mais il peut
siéger c'est plus pas la question la
question n'est pas là est-ce que c'est
possible oui est-ce que c'est envisagé
non et ses pouces mm et pourquoi
il faudrait avoir un événement qui
justifierait de le faire est ce que vous
avez ça sous les yeux aujourd'hui la
réponse est non mais en tout cas le
parlement puis les parlementaires
restent parlementaire je parle en tout
cas les sénateurs évidemment parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de processus électoral
mais les députés res débuté jusqu'au
dernier jour de leur élection est ce que
j'ai est ce que dans ce plan est
notamment ce vote vous avez intégré le
fait que les choses pourraient aller
mieux dans les prochaines semaines
oui alors m on a déjà usé bas d'ailleurs
je le rappelle au moment du de la
prolongation 2-2 pas sanitaires et des
dispositifs d'état d'urgence au mois
d'octobre ou novembre le texte juste
avant celui ci donc vous avez expliqué
qu'il fallait même arrêté le pass
sanitaire parce que on était en train de
sortir de la crise alors je voudrais
vous dire quelque chose cette crise nous
apprend à être modeste et prudent et
donc on est modeste et prudent et donc
j'entends tout ce qu'ils disent yaka on
va être sorti tous les épidémiologistes
de comptoir
nous sommes tous un peu sélectionneur de
foot épidémiologistes désormais mais moi
je considère que c'est des choses
sérieuses et que donc il faut qu'on ait
des outils qui nous permettent de
rapidement réagir et donc c'est dans
cette disposition la con et heureusement
qu'on n'avait pas supprimé les
dispositions
d'urgence ou préparant l'état d'urgence
sinon on serait dans une situation
devrait pas pu agir sur un certain
nombre de lieux même si ces malheureuses
sur les discothèques par exemple du coup
la présidentielle se déroulera à son
coville les sénateurs notamment
centristes et veulent des dispositions
pour encadrer le scrutin sur le plan
sanitaire est ce que ça manque dans le
texte actuel demande légiste négligé
pour mais ce n'est pas une affaire de
textes principalement le premier
ministre réunira demain si j'ai bonne
mémoire l'ensemble des forces politiques
avec la méthode que vous lui connaissent
et il réunit il prévient il dialogue on
prend des dispositions il réunira avec
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin je sais qu'on trouvera des
voies et moyens pour trouver la manière
de faire campagne a pas de raison qu'on
n'y arrive pas on y est arrivé si
c'était compliqué parce que là on était
dans une phase épidémique nouvelle aux
municipales minutes arrive aux
régionales et aux départements
regardez
on va alors sur ces sujets là il ya ce
qui est possible et ce qui est possible
dans le délai donc on va regarder et il
faut aussi qu'il y ait un consensus des
forces politiques me semble-t-il -
consensus aussi large que possible donc
on va regarder quelles sont les
propositions je viens pas préempter un
débat qui va commencer demain sur ces
sujets là qui avait déjà compris mais on
va regarder enfin je n'ai moi je n'ai
pas de davie il faut en tout cas dans
cette affaire là qu on est à trois mois
du scrutin que ces dispositions où les
dispositions les ajustements cda
justement qu'on pourrait faire soit
acceptée parce qu'ils vont concourir oui
mais dans la situation dans laquelle on
est nous de gouverner on va pas venir
imposer contre l'ensemble des forces
politiques des choses art fenway ce que
vous craignez la faiblesse de la
participation vous évoquez les
régionales et les mines et ça a été
quand même le principe est ce que vous
craignez pour tous les gens qui sont à
la fois qu'on regarde je pense qu'il ya
deux ans ceux qui peuvent craindre
d'aller dans les bureaux de vote encore
que ce n'est pas les lieux qu'ils soient
les lieux les plus à risque
objectivement pour avoir retenu moi même
mon bureau de vote dans ma commune de
marché n'aura donc joué à peu près de
quoi il est question et la distanciation
et les règles de prudence ce s'applique
au fond assez facilement dans un bureau
de vote même si ça va compliquer la vie
des élus et jour et salué le travail
qu'ils font pour essayer de faire les
choses dans les meilleures conditions
possibles donc il ya un premier un
risque c'est lui a pris un risque de
démobilisation générale donc sur les le
premier c'est d'essayer de rassurer de
mettre en place des protocoles qui sont
rassurants pour les gens peut-être
d'avoir des mesures d'assouplissement
appuyé sur le deuxième c'est à nous de
faire une campagne qui intéresse les
gens donc illicite et d'une vraie
campagne ah oui il ya nécessité d'une
vraie campagne alors est ce que c'est on
voit bien que est ce que les formats
meeting permanent d'ailleurs
objectivement depuis des années on voit
bien qu'il ya les très très grand
meeting écolo reste c'est un peu
amenuisé on va dire ça comme ça la
campagne de ce fait plus pareil
l'émergence des réseaux sociaux des
chaînes d'info continue elle en
particulier pour une présidentielle créé
des conditions qui sont particulières
donc pas tout à fait de toute façon les
vingt campagnes qu'il ya 20 ou 30 ans
voilà donc on va regarder on va juste et
les parties politiques hommage justement
d'ailleurs plus leur parrainage
la participation citoyenne est ce qu'il
faut changer les règles de parrainage et
remplacer des parrainages d'élus par des
panaches de citoyens écoutez on va pas
changer les règles à trois mois d'un
scrutin bon alors après quelques
questions se posent mais au bout du bout
à date et j'espère que ça restera ainsi
citez moi un candidat peu significatif
qui n'est pas pu être candidat ces vingt
dernières années
je sais pas si à dublin où vous à la fin
globalement les candidats qui pesait
quelque chose dans le débat public ils
ont été présents et parfois des
candidats qui ne faisait pas grand chose
donc pour vous la règle actuelle
fonctionne il ne faut pas être méchant
mais moi j'ai quand même question marc
raynaud est-ce qu'il faut revenir sur la
question de l'anonymat en tout cas non
publicité alors c'est là c'est la grise
et la wii alors moi j'ai connu la règle
de l'arrêt qui s'applique aujourd'hui
c'était la règle de 2002 c'est à dire
qu'on vendait rend fou au fur et à
mesure public les parrainages
puis on avait complètement anonymisées
puis on avait beau bref
est ce que c'est un frein je sais pas
les maires il exerce d'abord je rappelle
une chose parce que je vois beaucoup de
collègues maires qui disent
je parle comme un ancien élu ou un élu
que je suis pardon de le dire comme ça
qu'ils disent je vais consulter mon
conseil municipal au fond c'est pas une
nécessité puisque c'est le parrainage
n'est pas une caution des candidats le
parena chez je veux que cette personne
participe du débat démocratique il ya
des gens qui ont parrainé par x et les
gens qui n'étaient pas dans le champ est
dans le registre ça se comprend et ça
s'explique
dont il ya plutôt ça a expliqué dans
l'opinion y compris dans l'opinion
municipal c'est à dire que quand un
maire pareil tel ou tel candidat c'est
pas pour autant qu'ils en aient un
soutien et un premier défenseur mais je
pense que ça ça a disparu dans l'état
d'esprit en gros vous parrainez vous
soutenez donc il ya quelque chose à kaka
c'est de cet ordre là est-ce que
l'anonymat mais un temps l'idée que ce
qu'on se cacherait de soutenir tel ou
tel candidat me gêne je vois bien que ça
peut être un frein pour certains mais
l'idée que dans une démocratie ça
revient de ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur les me des élus qui sont
menacés en menacerait un élu à raison de
son parrainage à tel ou tel candidat on
est quand même dans un drôle de système
c'est quoi ces démocraties de l'anonymat
est-ce qu'il faut partager comme
abondamment sont partagés sur le sujet
non mais je je je j'assume tout à fait
c'est mais
ça facilite sans doute le fait qu'on
donne son parrainage mais ça me gêne
qu'on puisse pas assumer publiquement un
parrainage un candidat oui donc on s'en
partager mais moi je dis juste que les
faits sont têtus je demande à voir ce
qu'elle est le candidat aujourd'hui qui
significativement présents dans les eaux
dans l'opinion a n'a pas pu être
candidat je n'en vois pas donc je pense
que monsieur mélenchon est au fond c'est
heureux et monsieur zemmour pareil
seront candidats ils ont leurs
parrainages après je connais d'exercice
de ceux qui font monter un peu les
choses je ne parle pas de ces deux
personnalités là mais en soi et retenez
moi ou ça fait très peur aux tno j'ai
pas être candidat
cet exercice qualité de la campagne
donc annoncé son soutien et il
est élu guillaume pelletier du même
département vous il reproche notamment
valérie pécresse de faire le jeu
emmanuel macron qu'en pensez-vous
que guillaume pelletier est un
aventurier de la politique
fidèle politique est infidèle
territoriales il a été candidat à
epernay il a été candidat tour il nous a
expliqué ses racines solognote il nous a
dit combien il aimait le mandat de
municipal il est resté deux ans comment
il aimait le mien d'un régional il est
pas retourner au combat régional
qu'est ce que je voulais je vous dise la
vie politique est traversé de
personnalités comme ça ça veut pas dire
qu'il a pas du talent d'ailleurs mais
elle traversait de personnalités qui
sont à leur compte total aventuriers
totaux nous ça discrédite l'ensemble de
ses propos il a fait à peu près toutes
les boutiques il a été éphémère mans
centriste en 2015 au moment des
régionales pour pouvoir travailler avec
nous et que philippe vigier à l'époque
peut pas dire que ce soit la force des
convictions qui soit sa caractéristique
première mais à partir de là moi qui
n'ai pas changé de famille politique je
le regarde comme un être un peu étranger
à ma façon de faire de la politique et
avec pas plus d'intérêt que ça
figurez-vous parce que je il ya des gens
avaient l'air qui ont des convictions
ils ont droit les avoirs après sa pole
or donc voilà pour ce qu'ils
ont fait pas des tournants avec des gens
qui font des zigzags enfin je veux dire
pardon c'est ainsi d'ailleurs c'est une
bécasse pour revenir à la question sont
ceux du vol de la bécasse pour revenir
de pardon il sera temps d'y
laisser ma fille en revanche ça pose une
question aussi ou à l'air c'est qu'ils
ont acceptée dans leurs rangs
monsieur pelletier
or un petite interruption toujours été
sur une ligne très à droite et à force
d'avoir couru derrière monsieur zemmour
et d'avoir rhétorique de monsieur
zemmour les gens et préfèrent l'original
à la copie parts chez eux et pour donc
il faut que l air j'ai pas de conseils à
leur donner ce sont des adversaires
politiques printemps dans le débat
démocratique
moi je ne je ne cherche pas
l'humiliation des adversaires je pense
qu'on a besoin d'une gauche
on a besoin d'une droite mais à force de
ne pas choisir entre la ligne zemmour et
la ligne plutôt des républicains qu'on a
connu un sort chirac c'est assez
original de voir monsieur pelletier
défendre le rpr qu'il a pilonné quand il
était chez monsieur le pen parce que
c'était monsieur à l'époque et chez
monsieur de jijel info faut quand même
toute honte bue un bon peu importe mais
le rpr de jacques chirac ce n'était pas
un repère qui courait derrière monsieur
zemmour voilà et donc je pense que cette
confusion des esprits chez les leurs ils
sont en train de la payer et le départ
de monsieur pelletier qui est annick de
type pour ce qui est de la personnalité
il est symptomatique d'un une formation
politique n'a pas fait ses choix merci
pour merci d'avoir été notre invité
merci femmes